Hi, this is Dr.
Kolatner, we're going to
be discussing substance
use disorders.
Our objectives today
are to discuss the
use disorder,
intoxication dependence,
and withdrawal of
commonly encountered
substances in the
clinical setting, as
well as to explore
resources available
for providers and
patients in need of
information regarding
substance use. The
resources used for
this presentation
are the NIH websites
and booklets,
a few appropriate
research articles,
and approximately
100 pages of the
DSM-5, which is the
blueprint for the
NBOME substance use
disorder topics.
definition of substance
use disorder will
take many forms the
bottom line is that
it's a complex condition
in which people
continue to use a
substance even though
they know it's hurting
them more than it
is helping them the
need for the substance
impairs their ability
to function in
daily life and it is
Let's classify based
on how many of 11
criteria are fulfilled.
The first four of
the 11 criteria
are concerned
with impaired
control over the
substance use.
It includes
using more than
intended, the
desire to cut down,
spending a great deal
of time focused on
the substance, and
craving the substance.
Criteria 5, 6, and 7 are
concerned with
social impairments.
It includes
diminished ability
to work, attend school,
maintain personal
relationships,
and a decrease in
social activities.
Criteria 8 and 9
deal with risky use,
either in an unsafe
environment or by
an exacerbation of
personal problems.
Criteria 10 and 11
evaluate for tolerance,
which means needing
more of the substance
to get the same effect,
as well as withdrawal,
which means
experiencing physical
symptoms when the level
of drug is diminished.
These criteria do
not count in the face
of medically prescribed
substances. In other
words, if a patient
is prescribed an
opioid for pain and
uses it as prescribed,
they will likely
develop tolerance and
withdrawal, but should
not be considered
as having a substance
use disorder.
Alcohol use
disorders can be
defined as binging,
heavy drinking,
and high-intensity
drinking.
The exact definitions
vary by gender, volume
and time frame
statistically alcohol is a
national health risk
with children as young
as 12 years old
reporting heavy use and
teenagers reporting
binging 7% of emergency
room visits 17% of
opioid overdoses and 35
,000 deaths are related
to alcohol annually.
Alcohol use disorder
is defined as
a brain disorder
characterized by
the inability to
control its use.
Alcohol use disorder
is diagnosed
in 3.4 percent of
children between
the ages of 12
and 17 and 11.3
percent in adults
18 years and older.
The estimated cost
of alcohol use
disorder is two
hundred and forty nine
billion dollars
a year which is
about seven hundred
and seventy dollars
per person in the
United States.
Alcohol intoxication
signs include
the classic unsteady
gait, slurred
speech, and
impaired judgment.
On the exam you can see
nystagmus, flushing
of the face,
and injection of
the conjunctiva.
The patient may present
with a decreased
level of consciousness
or aggression.
Alcohol poisoning
occurs when the amount
of alcohol in the
blood overwhelms the
liver's ability to
remove the toxins.
The toxins are
produced by
the breakdown of alcohol.
Breathing, heart
rate, and blood
pressure will
all be depressed.
Additional
symptoms of alcohol
poisoning include
hypothermia,
incontinence,
and seizures.
Blood alcohol level
can be assessed
two ways, either
by measuring the
amount of alcohol
that evaporates
in your lungs or
by a blood test.
The blood test is
most accurate between
6 and 12 hours from
the last drink.
Management of
alcohol poisoning
will include
airway monitoring,
IV fluids, and glucose.
Thiamine is
given to prevent
Wernicke's encephalitis.
Helpful labs include
a CBC to evaluate for
infection and anemia,
a CMP to assess liver
enzymes, and an
echocardiogram. If mental
status is altered and
the etiology is not
clear, you may need a
CAT scan of the brain.
Haloperidol is
the preferred
medication to
manage agitation.
Withdrawal from alcohol
occurs after abrupt
sensation of heavy
or chronic drinking.
Fifteen percent
of the patients
will develop
DTs, delirium
tremors, and
possible seizures.
There must be a clear
history of alcohol
use and cessation to
make this diagnosis.
Diazepam is the
primary choice of
treatment for the
delirium tremors.
Thiamine must
be administered
prior to discharge just
like to make a general
comment about all
of these disorders
the history is going
to be integral in
making an accurate
diagnosis you have to
look for evidence of use
of a substance and
confirm that the
symptoms of the patients
experiencing is not
explained by any
other medical problem.
So on to tobacco
use. Tobacco use
disorder results
from the nicotine
binding in the
bloodstream.
Dopamine, norepinephrine,
acetylcholine,
glutamate,
serotonin,
beta-endorphin,
and GABA are all
released due to
nicotine binding.
This leaves a patient
feeling *******
less anxious and
less hungry nicotine
withdrawal is associated
with irritability
anger frustration
anxiety depressed
mood difficulty
concentrating increased
appetite insomnia
and restlessness
treatments are in
form of medication and
are either non nicotine
replacement or nicotine
replacement the non
nicotine replacement
medications are
varenicline also known
as Chantex it's the most
effective medication
we know so far it
is a partial agonist
Bupropion, also goes
by the name of Zyban,
is less effective
than Varenicline,
but much better than the
nicotine
replacement options.
In both,
dopaminergic
stimulation is blocked,
so craving and
withdrawal are reduced.
and then there
are the nicotine
replacement
medications as well.
Cannabis use disorder
can be acute or chronic.
Acutely it includes
intoxication
and withdrawal
with delirium,
psychosis, anxiety,
and insomnia.
Chronic use can lead
to disordered behavior.
Cannabis
intoxication, use
followed by
impaired motor
coordination, think
about driving,
euphoria,
impaired judgment,
think about parenting,
and anxiety.
Signs of cannabis use
include conjunctival
injection,
increased appetite,
dry mouth, and
tachycardia.
Cannabis withdrawal
can develop
about one week
after abrupt
sensation following
heavy use.
It consists of three or
more of the following.
Irritability,
anger, aggression,
anxiety,
insomnia,
weight loss,
poor appetite,
restlessness, and
depressed mood.
Hallucinogens cause
profound distortions
of a person's
perception of reality.
Hallucinations
can be either
physical, visual,
or auditory.
A list of the common
hallucinations
are on the bottom
of this slide.
Behavioral changes
following ***
intoxication include
belligerence, *****,
impulsive, unpredictable.
Signs include
nystagmus, hypertension,
tachycardia, a
diminished response
to pain, seizures,
and coma.
Glucinogenic
intoxication results in
clinically significant
problematic
behavior or
psychological changes.
Perceptual changes
that occur is a
state of full wakefulness
and alertness.
Inhalant intoxication
is problematic
behavior or psychological
changes associated
with dizziness,
nystagmus, and
coordination,
slurred speech,
unsteady gait,
lethargy,
muscle weakness,
visual disturbance,
stupor, or coma.
There are three different
types of opioids.
There are natural
opioids that
come from the poppy
plant, and these
include morphine
and codeine.
there are semi
-synthetic opioids that
are based on the
natural product but
still manipulated
in a laboratory and
those include oxycodone
hydrocodone and
****** and then
there are synthetic
opioids that are
completely man-made
such as fentanyl
methadone and tramadol
one-third of adults admit
to misuse of opioids
It usually starts in
late teens or early 20s,
and there is definitely
a genetic factor.
Opioid abusers are at an
increased risk for TB,
HIV,
endocarditis, hepatitis,
and cellulitis. Be
very wary of
fentanyl. It is 50
times more potent
than ****** and 100
than morphine.
Currently, it is
being isolated from 80
% of the patients
that are admitted to
an emergency department
for an overdose.
Of those 80% of
those patients, only
one-fifth are even
aware that fentanyl
was in the product
that they used.
Opioid intoxication
will have behavioral
or psychological
changes accompanied
by pupillary constriction,
intoxication,
drowsiness,
slurred speech,
or impaired
attention and memory.
This slide has a
helpful mnemonic
to evaluate
for opioid use.
Opioid withdrawal is
present when three
or more of the
following are present
within minutes to several
days after cessation
or opioid antagonist
administration,
dysphoric mood,
nausea and
vomiting, muscle
aches, lacrimation
or rhinorrhea,
pupillary dilatation,
piloerection or sweating,
diarrhea,
yawning,
fever, and insomnia.
Treatment for opioid
use disorder can
include methadone,
which is an agonist,
buprenorphine,
which is a partial
agonist. Both
of those will
reduce withdrawal
and cravings.
You You can also
use naltrexone,
which is an antagonist
and prevents
the opioid from
producing the rewarding
effects that
people are seeking.
Methadone and
buprenorphine are equally
effective, but both are
better than naltrexone.
And all of these
medications work better
with counseling and
behavioral therapy.
Intoxication with
sedatives, hypnotics,
and anxiolytics
will reveal
behavioral changes,
which can be ******
in nature, but
still aggressive,
moody, and displaying
poor judgment.
Signs and symptoms are
very similar to a lot
of the other forms
of intoxication, and
again, that's why the
history is so important.
This, in particular,
sedative intoxication
is easy to
confuse with alcohol
intoxication.
Withdrawal will
reveal autonomic
hyperactivity
such as sweating
or an elevated
heart rate,
hand tremors,
insomnia,
nausea or vomiting,
transient visual,
tactile, or
auditory hallucinations
or illusions,
psychomotor
agitation, anxiety,
and grand mal seizures.
This is just a
suggested flow chart
on how to evaluate
a patient for
intoxication or
withdrawal that enters
into your emergency
department.
Again from my
perspective, the
history is going
to give you
the most amount
of information.
Stimulant intoxication,
stimulants
such as ******* or
methamphetamine.
You'll see clinically
significant problematic
behavior or
psychological changes.
You'll see euphoria
or effective blunting,
changes in sociability,
hypervigilance,
interpersonal
sensitivity,
anxiety, tension
or anger,
stereotyped behavior,
and impaired
judgment that develop
either during or
shortly after the
use of a stimulant.
You will see
two or more of
the following
signs or symptoms
developing during or
shortly after use.
Tachycardia,
pupillary dilatation,
alterations in
blood pressure,
perspiration or chills,
nausea or vomiting,
evidence of weight
loss, psychomotor
agitation or retardation,
muscular weakness,
respiratory depression,
chest pain or
cardiac arrhythmias.
You can see
confusion, seizures,
dyskinesias,
dystonias or coma.
Chest pain and
palpitations are
a frequent
presenting symptom.
Withdrawal from a
stimulant will lead to a
dysphoric mood and two
or more of the following
physiologic changes
developing within a
few hours to several
days after cessation.
You can have fatigue,
vivid unpleasant dreams,
alterations in sleep,
increased appetite,
and alterations in
psychomotor status.
remember to diagnose
a withdrawal
you must have a
clear history of both
use and cessation
of use finally
here are some resources
for both you your
patients and their
families I just want to
note OASAS the fifth
ones from the top you
can email them and
they will send you the
nasal naloxone and
also train you on how
to use it it's something
that you can drive
around with in your
car keep in your home
and could save a life
knowing how to use
it and having it
available so something I
strongly recommend for
everybody as a provider
you should be very
very familiar with
the guidelines for
prescribing opioids and
if you're not already
familiar with the
prescription monitoring
program you should
become familiar with
it as the person
prescribing controlled
substances you are required
to check this website
which is a live
ongoing website that
updates patients
prescription filling at
the pharmacy so every
time a prescription
is filled this website
updates and as long as
you check it you will
be able to prevent
people from getting
too much medication
from too many providers
If you have any feedback
or any questions,
my email is acoladne
at nyit.edu and
I hope this has been
helpful for you.